like training for a marathon Blake
Lively reveals how she got bikini ready
for the shallows
self-reliance can do wonders Blake's
body is on full display in the film but
the actress tells et it wasn't easy to
get back in shape just ten months after
giving birth to her first child with
hubby Ryan Reynolds I was still
breastfeeding too so it was like it was
um I still had to be healthy I couldn't
go off and eat leaves all day and so it
was it was it was hard but it was also
again because it wasn't just for sake of
being in a bikini because I had to be
strong enough not to be injured because
I had to be able to keep up with a
physicality a role that was the the true
motivation and also while shooting we
shot for eight weeks and being in waves
like that swimming like that doing such
long takes like that all the time I
became so much stronger and more fit by
the end of production because I was
working out 13 hours a day because
shooting was working out there was need
to have that challenge after having a
baby because you think your body is so
different that you think no matter what
it's never gonna totally be the same and
to be able to be in better shape than I
had ever been in before I thought okay
that's really encouraging what is going
through your mind being by yourself on
these 13 hour days being away from your
family Ryan and James like we keep our
family together we don't ever work at
the same time and I've done that's what
makes it nice that's what it keeps it
easy it's really important for us to
have that support system so we're always
there were always together if not I
would nothing would be worth being where
my family Blake is now expecting baby
number two at the shelves premiere she
told ET she's feeling great